- It was very important to us
that you were seeing
various representations
of what it is to be a woman.
In "Lessons In Chemistry,"
there's so many examples on screen,
but then you also have it
behind the camera as well.
(upbeat music)
- Rolling!
- Mark.
- And...action!
- It's been so incredible
to walk onto these sets
where I have seen so many women in
producers and directors,
to have that understanding
and to move forward together
in this very daring way,
exposing our truths,
it's intensely wonderful.
- It's nice to have
anyone tell this story,
but it brings a little
bit more when it's someone
who may have experienced similar
things in their own career.
- Sweetheart, I could
use another cup of joe
when you're done with that.
- Most women on production
can understand trying
to claw their way into
getting taken seriously,
so to have our directors who
are all women commanding a set,
it was really cool to see.
- You're gonna be right here to go, boom.
- I'm Black female director in
a very male-oriented industry
so I understood that battle of saying
this is what I wanna
do, this is what I love,
why can't I do it, why
is it different for me?
- We have rules, Miss Zott.
Who do you think you are?
- A woman.
- When I started, there were
very few women around me.
You just kind of realized early on
that in order to get there,
you really have to be fierce,
but at the same time, be more gentle
because if you're not gentle as a woman,
then you're considered a bitch.
- How would you describe the host?
Stuck up, unpleasant, didn't smile once.
- There's a beauty to Elizabeth Zott,
but also good grittiness to her,
and we all can relate to that.
- Are those pants? Why
is she wearing pants?
- Whether it's costumes or
production design or props,
you're getting that experience
in every layer of it.
- Knowing there’s
like two or three women
or two or three people of
color in each department,
it makes it easier.
- On this project, I really
felt heard and trusted.
One ready to go for her to pull
and then maybe she cuts into-
- That's brilliant, Courtney.
- Yeah!
- If you are the most
capable at doing something,
you should get the opportunity to do it
and excel at it, period.
- Why would anyone
discriminate based on something
as intellectually
non-determinative as gender?
- Calvin,
how many female scientists can you name?
- Madam Curie?
- Exactly.
- If you're gonna do this, this industry,
or actually any industry, take up space.
Take up space the best way you know how.
Don't diminish yourself for others.
- You have a platform, what you say matters.
- The best piece of advice that I ever got
was from a fellow filmmaker
who told me to just do you,
and that changed my whole
perspective as a director.
Let me just see how you would do it.
- Pour it in and then
put it back on the flame,
tilting it slightly,
and then it should just go up in flames.
- Having women behind the camera,
it's just amazing to watch.
And then I know it's gonna
empower some little girl.
- I didn't know that it was possible
for me to work in a camera department,
and so for me to see these
women stand up and be like,
"Hey, I wanna bring the
camera over here," or,
"Hey, I like this type of
shot," is super inspiring.
- It's a really powerful feeling
to know that we are all here
because we wanna bring excellence to this,
because we know the story deserves it,
and that we're capable of bringing it.
- At the end of our time here together,
we will have done something worth doing,
and it will matter.
(soft music)